[Music]
james the producer emailed what probably
two weeks ago
and was like isn't this crazy this
played literally one year ago this clip
so i watch it
and during i'll say this during some of
our debates
you know a question like
dave he didn't he didn't really you
don't really know he didn't really get
it he's really missing the mark here on
this one he doesn't he doesn't see it
but on this clip specifically as i
watched it again a year later i thought
he's brilliant
he's like
who was like the old sidekick that was
like 800 the 1-800 number miss clea or
is that what it was she got arrested but
she didn't know it was coming so she
wasn't a psychic
i was watching i was like is dave
psychic okay so what we're going to play
for you is the cliffhanger it's just
psycho that's it
maybe both
uh that played
it played april 27th of 2021. okay we
got to get back everyone get back in
your mindset of 2021
of early 2021 okay the pan i mean steph
is still here
you know you're still wearing a mask on
airplanes covid was still like tr it was
still kind of all kind of around the
idea of it uh gas just started going up
car prices i do not think at this point
were outrageous the car thing had not
happened yet
again martin was barely in office yes so
again we are sitting one year ago um
basically today when this segment aired
so we're gonna play just a little bit of
it and we're gonna watch uh mrs clia do
her do her magic
have you felt this ever i mean for four
years i've never seen it like this
exactly yeah but uh in 19 in the 19 uh
what we are going to see out of this
that you've never seen your generation
has ever seen is inflation
inflation the components that make up
the inflation index housing is one of
them it's the biggest part of inflation
and when housing shoots up and oil
shoots up
and oil has shot up too yeah it has yeah
and uh you know you look at the gas pump
oh yeah oh i know i filled up my minivan
two days ago
nobody's talking about it but the gas
pump doubles and housing goes up a bunch
then all of a sudden you're going to see
stuff like i saw in the 70s and 80s
which was double digit inflation where
stuff's going up 10 15 a year and
inflation was out of control and the
politicians it took it you know it took
some real
strong
politicians to do away with it uh it was
out of control how do they do away with
it well i i credit ronald reagan and
just put the brakes on because it was
out of control under carter and he comes
in and shifted economic policy and uh
just started opening up
doing with regulation opening up the
markets because if you can flood the
market with supply
it slows down as flows down the feeding
frenzy because if you can get it
everywhere there's no scarcity sure then
the prices start to settle
you know if there's an oversupply prices
go down if there's an under supply
prices go up because there's people
chasing it sure
you know if you you know half the number
of people chasing it as there are you
know you got two houses for sale for
every buyer
well all of a sudden prices stabilize
start to go down start to or at least
quit shooting through the roof
so the out of control upward inflation
so we're probably going to see some
actual inflation out of this which we've
not seen in two decades you watch these
interest rates go up with inflation yeah
it'll shut this housing market down i
was going to say how yeah the
correlation between inflation and the
interest if you go from three to six
this housing market will freeze like a
deer in the headlights it'll just stop
people just stop buying they'll just
back up and wait
and uh that's you're going to see some
of that back and forth now it's going to
be a little rocky
a little volatile but it won't this
feeding frenzy that you've got right
this second is not going to continue
we're talking about the housing market
going into that okay so you predicted
inflation you were like inflation's
gonna happen your generation's never
seen it before but it will happen and i
remember thinking
oh
doomsday dave i don't know i don't know
if it'll happen inflation has happened
and then you predicted
that the interest rates for mortgages
will go up and now they're up to five
percent they've gone up in the last few
months so like inflation hit mortgage
price mortgage interest is going up
what
what's gonna happen next are we ready
for a recession predict the recession
predict it right now are we going to
recession but seriously is that not
crazy though that you
that well the signs were there it's not
i'm not no i know i know
those things were happening the
components of inflation were already
kicking in we were seeing prices jump
through the roof on things and the biden
administration on the things it could do
things about wasn't
for instance energy it the stuff at the
gas pump is his fault the other parts of
inflation the republicans are trying to
blame him for it's not his fault it's
pandemic's fault it was a supply demand
curve thing and so fox news wearing
biden out you know because they're
trying to get gop in at
uh
at the um
the midterms right so it's political on
blaming him for it but anyway the um
you know and and we are probably going
to see six percent i said we go from
three to six on mortgages and then i
said the housing market would freeze
like a deer in the headlights it will
it'll it'll it won't it won't go down
it's not going to be like 2008 i'm not
predicting it to go down but you know
two years ago in 2022 we had a 32
increase
in the cost of housing in america
the next year we had a 17 increase the
average increase over the years is about
four percent
and the reason for that is very simple
shortage of houses new houses there's 10
buyers 20 buyers for every house that's
on the market and when you've got those
kinds of pressures you're going to have
an artificial inflation it's a supply
demand curve inflation it's not a thing
it's not a prosperity type inflation
it's not a the economy's too heated up
thing but you know when people slow down
buying houses it will slow down the rate
of increase in houses they're not going
to go down i'm going to wait on real
estate values to come down you're going
to be you're going to be dead before
they come back down they're not coming
down they're just they're not going to
go up at 32 percent a year yeah and this
idea of 400 people bidding on one house
over the weekend stuff that's going to
go away because when you double the cost
of interest your payment on
on a 400 000 house goes up dramatically
sure okay so what yes so those two
percentage points
is get from three percent to five
percent yeah
it's getting devalued the bond market
like 35
the bond market is crashing with these
increases in interest and the market is
the market has gone down stock market
has gone down yes and that's because the
economy is slowing that's that's
recessionary okay so so the gdp
came out gross domestic product which
came out down
over the first quarter and if it goes
down two quarters in a row it's a
recession so we could be entering a
recession at the end of this quarter if
it continues to go down yeah we probably
will and you think we'll probably hit a
recession yeah i think i think we're in
one yeah i think we're right square in
the middle one i don't know how long
it'll last but uh it depends on how long
they keep monkeying with stuff in
washington yeah but um
you know they could have done a lot to
help the supply demand curve stuff like
getting the ships off the ocean
you know when you got billions of
dollars of goods sitting in the ocean
waiting to come on shore and you can't
get baby formula that's a false thing
caused by regulations and crap
okay get the stuff out of the cartons
and get it in the stores it's not and so
there's some stuff that that the
policymakers and the politicians can
actually do that it is their fault okay
so the recession word is a scary word
for a lot of people because the last
time we hit that was during the oath all
of that right so you hear the word
recession
recession simply means the economy is
not producing as much goods and services
as it used to and it can affect you
mainly it will affect your jobs
because the businesses that are not
growing do not hire
and businesses that are shrinking fire
they lay off uh it's not it's not
pandemic furloughs they say you know
economics are bad i have to show you
know we're we're laying you off
permanently that's what they'll do and
so there'll be some people losing jobs
so we've had this shortage of labor
you've got almost no unemployment rate
so bizarre it's like the weirdest it's
the weirdest mix it's a weird weird
weird gumbo and so but but
the stock market is slowing because
profits are down because the economy is
slowing even though prices are up yes
but people are spending not spending as
much as they were even six months ago
right we know that because their economy
is shrinking because there is not stuff
to buy
not stuff to buy uh they're fearful
consumers pull back yeah probably i
don't know but recession is not an
emotional thing and it's really honestly
it's um
it's kind of a natural second step
after a bizarre you know supply demand
inflation curve like this yeah so will
inflation go down
once the recession or that's all it'll
kind of work inflation will go down when
the supplies hit the market comes back
yep in each area you know stuff's gonna
stop shooting up when there's plenty of
stuff yes you know there's plenty of
cars cars will go down but there's still
not plenty of cars there's still a
shortage yeah you know so that that's
what's driving that so inflation is not
a feat our recession is not a feeling
it is two consecutive quarters of a
shrinking economy
it's you know it's not a feeling it's
just gonna it is a thing that's gonna
happen though this is the ramsey show